before you got into the room we were
talking about what a shitty texture
backer you are
do you remember who me yeah
wait wait you just you were saying it we
were talking about it you're bad at
texting
there's a there's like so many times
where i sent you a text
and then you just didn't respond and
then do you remember the time
when i was like hey man i sent you a
text that said
hey if if there's something that i have
done
to offend you
can you please let me know what it is
yeah you know otherwise i'm just gonna
stop
trying to communicate with you because
like i've you know and then i text you
back on that one you're like you're like
no come on dude it's crazy like uh
of course you haven't done it i love you
dude yes steve steve
okay steve [ __ ] listen to me man all
right yeah
you're one of my favorite people on
planet earth i did i love you no
honestly you are what that okay and um
everyone has a problem david spade same
thing when he came on here
a couple weeks ago you don't text back
you know everyone says that about me
and literally i'm trying to do it now
i'm literally trying to do it
because i know it's a character defect
i'm [ __ ] going to try to do it
it's what the thing is he made a really
good point what was it what is it
he said no response is a response
yeah oh it's not that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
no no no that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] no no no no
[ __ ] you no response no no response i
know what you're saying
with that no response is absolutely a
response and what is the response
you don't [ __ ] matter no that's not
that's not i don't [ __ ] care that's
because that's if okay if that's the
response
then that's not how i feel so that's not
the response
okay but if you send somebody that's you
misinterpreting
the respond as a response right
right so it's like if i don't respond to
you right you're
and you think to yourself wow no
response you know what i mean
is a response that's you saying that you
came up with that
because on this end it's like i didn't
barely even read your
text whoa that's even worse that's work
or no what are you doing right now dude
what do you do that's just everyone okay
okay
all right all right all right no just
listen all right so there's certain
people who's too or who do matter enough
for you to read their texts
and there's a lot of other people who
don't no no i love i want to go down
this line lane with you and we're going
to go down it
all right but i'm going to go down
fighting all right
so the one thing in your corners that i
do believe that you would respect david
spade
enough so so yeah exactly
right right it's not just that it's
everybody has
come on to this podcast and said
you don't text back okay yeah so it's
like
it's not a personal thing you know it's
just
the way i behave i'm starting to believe
that okay so that's number one
all right that's two that's number one
okay okay and here's the thing
is um let's go down this path so um
no response means that um
i don't when somebody goes like i hate
small talk
all right i hate small talk so like
somebody will text me and go
wow man it's really hot today right
i'm not gonna go yeah man it's summer
right right so i just don't text back
okay and and they they have a whole
thing for people like you it's the
it's the the thumbs up thing you got a
thumbs up done
so you should you would that you would
that feel better if i liked your message
yeah i mean some kind of acknowledgement
would be uh would be kind of cool all
right you know what
you know you're right because say for
instance
i'm thinking about the people that i
care about in my life and it doesn't
matter how
mundane or dumb or boring or whatever
[ __ ] stupid
text they send me i will never not text
them back because i genuinely care
okay about them stop right that's why i
personally
[ __ ] hate my birthday and holidays
and stuff because
because my phone is just like all
[ __ ] day long and and and for me like
i would it's inconceivable to me that i
would not
respond wait wait you respond to all the
happy birthday messages you get
yep yeah like when somebody sends me a
text it's like okay like here's this
person and
like you know i'm not too cool for them
like i'm gonna
i'm gonna respond so like when i when i
get swamped by text it's it's
overwhelming for me and
and i i don't hate the people texting i
hate my [ __ ] birthday for bringing
right right okay let me just defend my
point one more time okay
okay let me go back to my thing all
right so when jordan peele
won his oscar right i texted him
oh man i'm crying right now dude
congratulations i'm so proud of you he
liked my text
he hearted it he hearted it yeah right
in my head i'm like i'd rather him not
respond
what oh yeah yeah because in my head it
goes to
he probably if i was um seth meyers
or jimmy fallon it's just in my twisted
head
he probably would write out the words
thanks a lot man i worked hard man but
this is a miracle whatever
but for me it's like uh it's in my head
i'm sure that wasn't his intention it
probably wasn't right
but in my head i'm thinking oh [ __ ]
bobby just [ __ ] it
there you go and just do that you know
and move on so i'd rather have him not
respond
right right okay right so it's like in
my thinking but maybe
i'm not looking at it as the victim's
point of view
so from now on so from now on you know
what dude you just [ __ ] swayed me
i am gonna either respond with a like a
love or a [ __ ]
smiley face or emoji or something it's
either you want to build a relationship
and sustain a friendship or you don't
i'm about to give you a compliment too
steve
i was about to go give you a really
throw it out anyways i'll do it anyway
let me change face
let me change face okay
so it's so creepy um
here's another thing i love about you
and this is
and you just take it just take it okay
okay
is you know stand-up comedy is something
i started with